good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast and happy wednesday happy
hump day
hope everyone's having a great start to
their hump day humping someone they love
your dog your man
your woman you're anyone your sister
your co-host
you say the word jackie and i can have
it all arranged
clear this studio out give us some
private time we'll start playing
conjunction junction what's your
function
nothing like a little incest tumor
before you've had your morning toast
like so twisted that's us um it's a big
day it's a big day let me tell you why
it's wednesday which is just like an
important
thing to acknowledge of course we're
getting over the hump we're getting over
the hump we've got an amazing show for
you guys we've got stories we've got
deer toasters we've got even an update
from one of our previous deer toasters
so that's very exciting but it's also
the first um tonight is our first live
show we are doing if you missed our
instagram announcement and our
announcement on the toast yesterday like
if you missed both like you're probably
like not a toaster but whatever um we
have a new show coming out it's called
breaking bread it is a live show with
spotify live so if you want to listen
tonight the the episodes are at 7 pm
eastern time 4 p.m pacific time if you
would like to listen live be able to
write in the chat we're going to be
doing interactive games where we bring
people up on the stage to talk um you
have to download the spotify live app
which is super easy it's free and then
you just follow us breaking bread that's
the name of our show you can also if you
don't like you know what you want to
listen more passively you can listen on
spotify you can listen live on the
regular app and if you miss it you can
also listen later on this week whenever
you want so you can live on both apps
but if you want to engage interact and
be a part of the show chat even if you
don't want to come up to the stage you
have to download spotify live and it's
super easy to download we're super easy
to find where you're verified queens
so join us tonight at 7pm eastern time
i'm excited i'm nervous we've never done
uh well we have but like you know
there's our first official episode of
breaking bread it's our first official
episode of breaking bread so for that
reason i'm very excited to get on with
it but we're live queens
and it's gonna be just like an evening
face time with jackson claude i know we
like we pretty much do a spotify live
every single night and every afternoon
in every midday yeah so it'll be super
fun i'm really excited about that so
make sure you tune in
tune in so you'll be hearing a lot of us
today yeah and that's just a gift from
us to you
you're welcome yeah welcome what can i
say
you're welcome i saw something that i
thought you might find interesting
please share i saw something interesting
too i sent it to olivia and she was like
i already knew that because she's like
literally nobody on the planet can know
more about moana than olivia
did you know that there's like a
conspiracy theory about moana you know
let me just read it because i'm gonna
totally um
people love to make consumers theories
about disney movies and it's like these
disney
writers really have thought of
everything all the backstories and
everything olivia was sending me
conspiracy about beauty and the beast
how like the beast was cursed when he
was 11 and it's like
alan menken didn't slip he didn't get an
egot to slip yeah okay so this is a
theory a lot of people believe about
moana you know how like she goes out she
gets caught in a storm it's treacherous
and then like she's fine and
dwayne johnson is there yeah
so moana actually died in the storm at
the beginning of the movie and then maui
is her guardian angel who has tasked her
to get to te fiti which stands for
heaven in the movie so the whole movie
is basically about her journey to the
afterlife
which honestly i didn't think was like
that crazy no it's not that crazy
but it's very sad mm-hmm
she passes in the prime of her life as
she's about to become queen it's tragedy
who will the crown pass too i don't know
interesting well i read an interesting
fact on one of those link nyc's that are
so unnecessary but they do put up some
interesting facts and like every quote
about new york that's ever been said by
anyone remotely relevant so
they also said
that there are just over 2 000 new
yorkers who are over the age of 100
according to the most recent census um
isn't that an interesting fact i don't
trust the census because like most
people just throw them out no i feel
like people respect the census um did
you do it i didn't get one you could do
it online
i think you probably did it
well i'm not gonna um perjure myself is
that the right word i don't think it's
illegal not to do the census it's just
like well if it's not illegal then i
definitely threw it out but if it's
illegal i fully submitted it i got it
okay well anyways
that's interesting is that more or less
than you would have thought i never
thought about me neither i never thought
about it and this is a tough city it
must be even tougher if you're 100. oh i
can't even imagine except you could if
you're technologically savvy get
everything to your doorstep yeah or if
you have a
grandchild who respects you yeah and is
helpful i'll never understand people who
disrespect their grandparents not
disrespect but not like
even if they're like nice to their
grandparents don't spend like as much
time as possible with them especially if
they live alone like
girl but i think
you get to an age where you realize that
unfortunately by the time we got to that
age all of our grandparents were gone
yeah no that's true it's like a maturity
thing yeah but whenever i'm on tick tock
i like see these videos of like people's
grandparents like begging them to hang
out and it is so that's really sad
it's like why are the grandparents on
tick tock
no no
no sorry
the people the grandchildren make tick
tocks like cute texts my grandpa sends
me and he's like [ __ ] he's literally
begging you to hang out like go get your
ass over there no get your [ __ ] ass
up and take care of your grandparents
hundred people some of us don't have
grandpa it seems like nobody wants to
take care of their grandparents these
days that's exactly what i'm saying
i understand um so what else you want to
kiki about before we start the official
show what's new with you how's harry
talking about me obviously yes he does
love his dear dear auntie but he is good
it was a busy morning as it always is
and
i'm just grateful for the opportunity to
show up and show out on a wednesday and
you're grateful for the opportunity to
be harry's mom
every day in every way our outfits today
while we're not matching we are giving
cosmo and wanda energy even though
you're like a little more purple than
pink yeah but maybe you know the lens is
a little saturated showing me pink and i
just want to let you guys know that we
are slick ex
look at my hair it's oily as [ __ ] show
them the pomade we're slick as [ __ ]
we literally have pomade on hand that's
how slick we are and actually you know
what we're slickening the studio down
we're slickening the studio down and
you're breaking the stupid i dropped the
pomade i think it's fine
okay that [ __ ] is extremely durable oh
for sure for sure chris appleton
wouldn't recommend it if he didn't
you're saying kim uses this pomade do
you ever think like are there a couple
things in your life that like moments or
experiences that you think of and
immediately like physically cringe a
hundred percent i would say i had one
the other day i was in the street too
and i made a grimace and i was like i
hope no one thought that was directed at
them i had one last night but the one
that i'm referring to now is the fact
that like we interviewed chris appleton
and we looked like actual like beasts
our hair was so disgusting
i was getting on a flight so like i
looked really bad both were getting out
for the cmas oh okay until we were spray
tanned like we were a couple of
bucks yeah we were like do you want to
put on makeup because we got fresh spray
tans we were like gonna have to hair and
makeup like the next day so we need to
do our hair and it's like the next day
we looked like the most gorgeous queens
and we've ever looked that was blue
dress like short blue dress for me
you wore
sparkly silver sparkly silver like we
were the most gorgeous we've ever been
in our whole lives but the day before
and that's what happens like when you
get a spray tan it's really a journey
before you take that shower and you look
like this
uh it's a low it's a you don't look
great and so we were like you know what
we'll hop on the plane from the toast so
i'm not gonna like i'm gonna wear low
bun whatever
and we looked like a couple of clowns we
looked like clowns like we're sitting
here with this world-renowned man who's
literally touched the hair of the most
iconic women in pop culture giving us
his best hair tips and he's like looking
at us like
who booked me on this show because
they're getting fired yeah and it's like
why are these girls talking about glam
they clearly have no interest yeah like
they personally what is this a podcast
about science they clearly have no
personal interest in the matter so
that's like one of the top ten times i
was actually just thinking about that
because it was chris appleton's birthday
and so kim posted like a bunch of
pictures of them and like they were so
iconic and it's really like kim and
chris like always doing it and the other
thing it's like we had our shot with him
and we blew it
but the other thing about chris appleton
is that he is literally so hot
it's just like you you just don't expect
that like he's so handsome and even more
handsome in person yeah love that
so that's the time we embarrassed
ourselves one of the many one of the
there are so many and what's
a little nerve-wracking because you know
there are going to be so many more yeah
more
more
okay
now you feel like you're ready to dive
in i feel ready i feel confident i feel
strong and i feel courageous you have
your swim cap on and you're ready to
dive in
i'm off the deep end watch as i dive
into the fast five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
lollipop you guys know we love soda and
there's a new kind of soda that tastes
amazing and is actually good for you and
it requires no balsamic vinegar that
episode should have been brought to you
by lollipop but i'm glad that this one
is so it tastes just like soda lollipop
it's like the ones you grew up with but
unlike other sodas there that are full
of sugar corn syrup and artificial
ingredients like aspartame lollipop has
is made with natural ingredients that
are actually good for you it is the
fastest growing beverage in a functional
beverage in america and they have
delicious nostalgic flavors like vintage
cola classic root beer orange squeeze
cherry vanilla strawberry vanilla and
their new flavor which is the classic
grape
you know we can't get enough soda here
at the morning toast and honestly it's
nice to switch it up with a healthy
alternative that really tastes
so good it's much lower in sugar
lollipop than conventional sodas it has
only uh two to five grams of sugar from
natural sources there's no sugar added
and their vintage cola which is a
personal favorite of mine has just two
grams of sugar compared to regular
coca-cola which has 39 grams all their
products are non-gmo they're vegan
they're paleo they're keto friendly and
they have less than eight grams um net
carbs per can they're so confident that
you'll love their product that they
offer 100 money-back guarantee for
orders placed through their website so
receive 20 off plus free shipping on
your order we recommend trying the
variety pack it's a great way to test
all of their delicious flavors and you
can get it at olliepop drink
olliepop.com so it's drink ollie pop
o-l-i-p-o-p dot com toast or you can use
the code toast at checkout to claim this
deal the website is drink ollie pop dot
com slash toast d-r-i-n-k-o-l-i-p-o-p
dot com slash toast lollipop can also be
found in over 8 000 stores across the
country like walmart target kroger whole
foods sprouts and publix so if you're
getting yourself a little pub sub pick
up an ollie pop for the side today's
episode is also brought to you by thuma
your bedroom deserves a refresh and now
is the perfect time to elevate the most
important room in your home with thuma
thuma practices an intentional less is
more design philosophy for the bedroom
with clean lines subtle curves and
lifestyle enhancing details fuma
provides proves that simplicity is the
truest form of sophistication
so introducing their bed the bed by
thuma is handcrafted from eco-friendly
high quality upcycled wood
you'll find beautiful unique variations
in the natural grain the minimalist
design feature has japanese joinery it
helps elevate any space and it's super
supportive for your mattress it's
breathable and it's made to naturally
minimize noise and create
space they also obviously they have the
bed they also offer other bedroom
essentials to elevate your bedtime like
the nightstand the side table and the
tray they are perfect complements to the
bed so um if you're looking for a
bedroom refresh if you spend a lot of
time in your bedroom you guys know we do
it is our home it is our shower it is
our kitchen um
you deserve to treat yourself to a nice
bed make it look sophisticated very kim
kardashian sumo also works with one tree
planted to plant one tree for every bed
and nightstand sold so all of their
essentials are green guard gold
certified and you can feel good knowing
you're helping the trees
create that feeling of checking into
your favorite boutique hotel suite but
at home with the bed by thuma and now go
to thuma dot co slash toast to receive a
25 credit towards your purchase of the
bed plus free shipping in the
continental us go to thuma
t-h-u-m-a dot c-o slash toast that's t h
u m a dot co slash toast thuma dot co
slash toast for that twenty five dollar
credit thank you claudia i have one
thing to say
zuma
zuma zuma zuma
when you say zuma like a bunch of times
it starts to sound weird
yeah i know it sounds like i have a lisp
yeah totally
not that we're making fun of people with
lists no but i used to have the
craziness yes oh my god i forgot about
that yes so i guess i can say that you
know wait let's talk about that let's
dive in i totally listed i forgot you
have to you used to have the biggest
list you did like speech pathology
speech therapy yeah and um i worked my
way out of it
sally sells seashells by the seashore i
have like a vivid memory of like us
being really young i think you had like
just started those speech classes and we
were all in our parents bed
and you like were doing it and i was
like look i could do it yeah [ __ ]
because you don't have a lisp like
sally sells seashells by the seashore
thanks claudia do it sally sells
seashells by the seashore it's really
not an issue anymore no it's a
memory
yeah yeah yeah wow
those are the days thank you
that memory is brought to you by
[Laughter]
bringing families together our first
story halsey compares adam sandler's
daughter's craziest bat mitzvah to
coachella
the sandlers know how to party just ask
halsey the singer who performed during a
bat mitzvah for adam sandler's 13 year
old daughter sonny back in may compared
the celebration to uh california's
iconic coachella music festival she said
first of all it was the craziest
craziest bat mitzvah i've ever seen in
my life she told jimmy fallon during uh
the guest appearance on the tonight show
quote as you would expect from adam
sandler it was like i mean it was like
coachella i couldn't believe it i was
like wow you guys booked me i was really
honored halsey said it felt like a full
circle moment they used to watch adam
sandler movies all the time okay so i
didn't even know adam sandler's daughter
had about mitzvah but i'm like obsessed
with the story um the fact that it was
like the biggest extravaganza coachella
like makes perfect sense like name a
more famous jew eight crazy nights like
adam sandler is literally like our
spokesperson and he's like one of the
few jewish celebrities who's like really
proud of his judaism like he's always
talking about it it's in his movies like
yeah so he's our leader he's our
representative and the fact that his bar
mitzvah his daughters bought mitzvot was
a blowout like is exactly what our
community needed and i'm extremely
grateful
yeah i agree i didn't even think about
it in that way it's like if adam sandler
isn't having the biggest baddest spot
mitzvah then who is right
if adam sandler is not getting halsey
right to perform
who is no i love this story so much i
love that halsey respects adam sandler
and i just i'm upset i wasn't invited
and i wish like obviously she's not
going to blow up the details but i kind
of want to know more like was it in
manhattan what was a venue like yeah i
would love to know i also i just have to
say one thing because i was seeing like
this video that was stalling on the link
page and i was scared that for what it
meant and i just googled it quickly and
it is what it seems charlie puth also
performed at the bat mitzvah
okay the thing is is that like i'm sure
adam sandler didn't choose the guests
his 13 year old daughter did um
and that's definitely upsetting like you
obviously i was writing a high like so
excited about the story and you just
ruined it yeah um
but i can move past it because in the
name of judaism for god you know i can
move past it 100 and also jennifer
aniston made a guest appearance which
makes sense because they are like the
dynamic rom-com duo okay wait so i
actually saw adam sandler and drew
barrymore do this like cute skit on
jimmy fallon talking about like rom-com
husbands and like how adam sandler's
drew barrymore's rom-com husband who do
you think blended 51st dates okay who do
you think is like adam sandler's go-to
rom-com wife is it jennifer aniston or
is it drew barrymore i think it's
jennifer anderson because they did um
just go with it they did that recent one
about murder on the train yeah and
they're doing another one and when he
won
a big award recently or she won a bigger
reward recently
i think jennifer aniston won the award
he introduced her it was like at the mtv
movie awards and he wrote this like
whole long thing i thought that that was
his partner
just like like ryan gosling and emma
stone just like bradley cooper and
jennifer lawrence yeah no i think adam
sandler is kind of like
like a man [ __ ] when it comes to
leading ladies i guess you could have
more than one but especially when you do
as many movies as adam's
but i personally think i prefer jennifer
aniston and adam sandler which is
surprising for me now that i'm thinking
about it yeah
i actually the the types of movies that
adam sandler does with jennifer aniston
i've never seen i've never seen just go
with it i don't think i've ever seen
just go with it too is there a second
one no you've never seen the one where
he's the dentist and she's pretending to
be his wife no like brooklyn decker yeah
no i've never seen that it's pretty
premium no okay maybe i'll add it to my
list i've also never seen the murder
ones
not bad so um i'm more leaning towards
drew barrymore even though like when i
think of
i don't know well you know what it kind
of works because it's like maybe
jennifer aniston's the first wife and
then drew barry more's the second wife
and then and then they have to blend
yeah blend and then they blend have you
ever seen
the drew barrymore ben steeler movie the
duplex
no
it is the most random movie i don't
think it was very popular i saw it one
time on cable years ago and now whenever
it's randomly on i watch it it is
probably the funniest movie it's so
underrated let me just tell you the
premise
so they're like this young married
couple so in love and they're looking
for a house to buy and they end up like
getting this amazing price for this
sickening duplex um in this building and
like the only other tenant in the
building is like this really sweet old
lady it's like literally a dream come
true
and as it turns out it's like a setup
that this old lady is like this evil
it's i don't want to spoil it it's the
and
they thought they bought their dream
home and they end up like so miserable
it is the best movie if you've ever seen
duplex like you know you know okay maybe
i'll check it out i'll watch just go
with it and you watch duplex you will
literally love it like this old lady
you're just it's so good oh i can't wait
i can't sing the praises enough if we
ever brought back to us movie of the
week that's like one of my underrated
films if we ever brought it back which
we're not so no i don't think so don't
get excited
uh also another rom-com couple that i
like is cameron diaz and jason siegel
yes that's extremely because they were
in bad teacher which is the best movie
if you haven't watched it it might be
new here if you haven't watched it and
you must you absolutely must but then
they were also in sex tape which stunk
yeah which freaking stung yeah sorry
wait let's think what are other rom-com
couples like people who are always doing
[ __ ] together
i feel like for a while it was like
catherine heigl and
like something she didn't have a one no
she got everyone she's butler josh dumel
james
marsden
james martin is so cute he's everything
who what is your favorite james marston
role on the count of three oh hold on i
mean
it's this is hard
is it hairspray i said on the count of
three but that's what you're saying
quinny collins yeah yeah but also
enchanting
yeah that's good
for the latest greatest
baltimore
sound oh every afternoon when the clock
strikes four
crazy bunch of kids crashed through that
door yeah
so throw up their coats and leave the
squares behind and you can shake it
shake it shake it like you're losing
your mind you never see them round
they're the nicest kids in town
roll call
i'm amber
chad
mikey vicky
becky
darlene charlene and i'm
link
and i'm tracy
i [ __ ] love hairspray so much and i
love like the most recent one we've
we've done literally whole episodes
about how no movie on planet earth has
ever been better casted than the most
recent version of hairspray amanda bynes
not live
not live no amanda bynes michelle
pfeiffer queen latifah like could it be
better no ariana no zac efron i'm sorry
not ariana grande no amanda bynes was a
better yeah yeah zac efron james marsden
james marsden it's literally so star
john travolta christopher walken it is
so star-studded honestly i can't get
into it but like if i was in college i
would write
a paper on it but that just like gave me
a serotonin burst i don't know about you
that [ __ ] song from that oh every
afternoon when the collection is like
i've never wanted to live in the 60s but
i'm like i could [ __ ] do it like
mashed potatoes on my ass all over town
on the courtney collins show
courtney by the way would you rather be
on the courtney collins show or shake it
up chicago because they're literally the
same show oh
i don't know
so good good question
good question like my dream really is to
play tracey turnblad in some sort of
production because i know the songs like
so well you you are to tracey turnblad
what tracy turnblad was to the courtney
holland show yeah like
back and forth knows all the dances yeah
i [ __ ] love that movie so good watch
that there's not a bad song
actually
when michelle pfeiffer seduces
christopher walken in the toy shop fast
forward fast forward yeah
okay now i feel ready for our next story
which i'm glad you chose as you did
choose four out of the five because it
gives me a chance to talk about
something else haley bieber's beauty
brand is officially here get a first
look at rhodes debut skincare products
hayley bieber has officially joined the
ranks of celebrities with their own
beauty brands on wednesday the model
introduced road a minimalist scare skin
care label that shares the model's
middle name
touted in a press release is providing
affordable luxurious products with
thoughtful intention that deliver gentle
effective skincare to invest in yourself
for the long haul her five sku offering
will be sold direct to consumer via its
own website roadsticking.com
worddiskant.comroaddeskin.com
i wish is that the end of the story um
do you want to hear more about the
products no no i read lip balms the
serum i looked it up this morning
because i wanted to purchase but it's
not out till 2 p.m eastern time okay you
set your alarm
no like if it's meant to be i'll
i'll be ready you know what i mean yeah
well i'm glad for haley i mean she does
have wonderful skin and affordable
skincare like this this is a vibe for
sure but i do want to talk about the
fact that i got the
skn by kim pr package i need to talk
about it because i haven't yet okay go
um it's amazing so
i got the new skin pr package first of
all the package itself came in this
gorgeous huge tote like girl never needs
a beach bag again thank you kim it came
with custom robe slippers and one of
those why custom it says your name skin
it says skin oh okay yeah sorry no no
sorry i was just confused um
you know you're being consuming no no no
no no no no i was like oh my god they
give you literally one with your name no
it was like custom for skin pr i don't
know if you could buy them so you
definitely can't maybe you can like the
headband thing that you probably skims
skims for skin yeah and so as we know
it's a nine step routine it's very
much a higher price point and i wasn't
sure if i was going to try it but my
skin has been really bad since i gave
birth it hasn't been really bad it's
just been different it's been different
a lot because i'm not sleeping a lot
like i feel like if i got like 12 hours
of sleep a lot of it would clear up but
i don't have that option so i have a lot
of redness just like
irritation not very hydrated you know
dull i'm not the girl i used to be look
at things are changing so i was really
excited to try a nine-step routine that
like maybe could help me and it was
amazing
every product i really enjoyed i watched
the video of kim doing it so i knew what
order to use things in because it
definitely has to go in order you know i
found that extremely helpful because i'm
always like what the [ __ ] order serum
cream cleanser like what are we doing
usually i know that it goes oil
actually like when i use sunday riley's
vitamin c trio
oil serum cream
but for kim the oils were last now that
i think about it the serums were second
very interesting very very uh i loved it
some of the stand out products the
exfoliator yeah was one of the most
gorgeous exfoliators i ever used the
beads were so tiny and it smelled so
good most of the other things i think
that you should yeah because you've now
mentioned it twice and i love i think an
exfoliator is like the key to having
smooth skin yeah and i use like an olay
henriksen one which is fine uh-huh but
i'm ready for a new one it was really
nice and the other products didn't have
fragrance i don't know what the smell
was but it was just like really nice
wafting in my shower
everything else was really good the eye
cream the cream the night oil
i used it two nights in a row but then i
got a spray tint like then i couldn't
use face product but i've really been
enjoying it and i i imagine that like
kim does use it because it's good stuff
yeah no i agree and then after i tried
it i was like i didn't couldn't remember
a world before
skin you know yeah that's you know when
that happens of course like before i
tried it i was like hmm do we need this
now i'm like
who who said that do you think we need
road
i think someone needs road yeah because
you want to know why like and i'm not
sure if you know this because i
literally spend my entire life on tick
tock but like haley bieber is so
influential in terms of like looks and
skin
makeup and glam like
and not in an intentional way i just
think she's really herself and like
wears things and does looks that she
wants and it's people are always like
seeking inspiration from her yeah so i
do think she's the perfect person to do
something like this and i really do like
that it's affordable because if you
think of her her like hardcore followers
it's like a lot of justin followers so
it's young people and i think the
affordable aspect of it is really great
i wasn't like totally blown away by the
packaging it was kind of like boring
but that really doesn't matter yeah when
it comes to skincare it's like what's
it's on the inside that counts
that is true also
yeah i think that she is that girl she
does have great skin but also her skin
is like young and it doesn't need
crazy heavy lifting so i think just like
affordable skincare that reminds her
young fans like moisturize your face
take your makeup off
you'll thank yourself in the long run
right i don't think it's for someone who
might struggle with their skin yes in
terms of acne like back and forth with
rosacea right i don't think it's that i
just think for like basic hygiene and
maybe she'll you know elevate because
it's a small collection to start it's
like three lip five products and three
of them are lip balms right so
i think the branding has been really
good i really like the name i'm just
like not crazy about like the packaging
is giving very like clinical like yeah
vibes yeah and i said that i i wasn't
crazy about kim's packaging so i didn't
know if it would match my bathroom which
by the way it does and like i like that
it's minimal like i'm tired of having
like a lot of ugly colors dumb crap in
my house no i have like an acrylic
tray slash holder to put all my
sink things in so that's like my
cleansers my skincare toothbrush
toothpaste pumice stone like just
everything in one little thing and it is
so ugly like every time i walk to my
bathroom i want to literally throw the
whole thing in the trash it's just like
disgusting yeah
so
i'm happy for road i hope you try it let
us know what you think yeah no if i if i
find myself like available at 2 p.m
eastern time
um i'll get into it thanks get into it
yeah
it's available available now
i'm not okay okay so get into it then i
got my rode skincare
um
here
i guess i could do this later okay a
peptide glazing fluid like i don't know
what that is i'll tell you it's touted
as the dewy hydration layer and the
hybrid serum gel designed to hydrate
skin as well as instantly illuminate it
for a glazed finish i could just get the
whole kip like dead ass
like this would be just for research it
would have to be a business expense
because i literally don't need any of
this i certainly don't need three lip
balms such as salted caramel and
watermelon slice
like i really don't no you don't i'll
look into this later okay honestly i'm
not going to spend a hundred dollars i
understand are you ready for our next
story no
yes
the next story is brought to you by the
new starbucks bia energy drink with
caffeine naturally found in coffee fruit
it's energy that's good it's a beverage
that's crafted from caffeine naturally
found in coffee fruit as well as
antioxidant vitamin c it includes three
delicious flavors mango guava raspberry
lime and pineapple passion fruit it is a
refreshing
fruit flavored boost of feel-good energy
in a way that only starbucks can deliver
each 12-ounce 90-calorie can contains
160 milligrams of caffeine and if you're
looking for a way to get your caffeine
fix and coffee is not your vibe like for
me i don't drink coffee but every now
and then you need a nice pick-me-up
check out the starbucks by energy drink
we actually have them in studio they're
really good i really like the mango
guava um
and it's just a fabulous thing to keep
around starbucks buy energy drink is
available online at grocery stores
convenience stores and gas stations
nationwide thank you starbucks by energy
drink for sponsoring this important next
story important next story that i love
so much shaquille o'neal pays the tab
for the entire restaurant after a date
with a mystery woman
the retired basketball star who is now a
sports analyst arrived to chelsea hot
spot oolong club with a mystery woman
around 8 30 p.m by the end of the night
he was footing the bill for the entire
eatery spies told page six he popped in
with the unidentified woman whom he was
over her describing as my date and
ordered beijing chicken shrimp tempura
and the restaurant's signature chicken
satay she did all the ordering an
insider told page six after their meal
he proceeded to buy dinner for the
entire server team and to top that off
he paid for everyone's check who was
dining at the
restaurant he wanted to keep his
generosity a secret from fellow diners
he asked the staff not to mention that
he was paying the bill for over 40
tables until he rep left the restaurant
according to the source they're told the
bill amounted to well over 25 000
in checks they said he was also
extremely generous to the restaurant
staff he left them the biggest tip
they've ever received plus if you want
to get even more p john a rep for him
did not get back to page six when they
reached out about the expense of date
night because he really didn't want
people to know he's an anonymous
charitable king which is the best kind
of charity oh my god okay so
first of all i hear about this happening
a lot with like especially with athletes
who make like insane money and i just
want to know like why i've never been in
the restaurant when that happens like i
would love for my meal to be picked up
but not not to make this without me but
just once i'd like to be there
the second thing is like this is my
favorite thing that celebrities do like
going to grocery stores like it is so
and honestly even if they're doing it
for publicity it doesn't bother me
because it's still so nice there's so
many things you can do for publicity so
to choose that one
more people should yeah i just i love it
i love shaq but it does make me think
about like dating shaq
oh because it makes me think about
adding him to our list yes because shaq
and khloe kardashian
that's good yeah i feel like they're
also around the same age yeah maybe he's
like a little bit older and like he was
an athlete and obviously that's of
interest to her but now he's a sports
analyst he's a businessman
and i think that's probably a blend of
what chloe needs wait that's such a good
call first of all and also like it it
takes an extraordinary woman i think
physically
to be with shaq i mean he must weigh
400 pounds
he's like seven feet tall he is so wide
he's so muscular
i
i can't even imagine what it's like to
like roll around in a bed with jack it
must be overwhelming honestly
yeah um i wanna see like he just got
divorced in 2011
and she was i believe tiny yeah well
everyone looks tiny next to him that's
true
really cute couple he's so cute like i
literally die for jack
ben is always watching that show nba on
tnt
we're like him and charles barkley and
the other two irrelevants
they just like kiki and like make fun of
and it is like that's really what sport
shows are zach watches two
every single day and their play in my
mind and the one of the ones that he
watches is like three hours because it's
a podcast
it's uh the herd with colin cowherd
and he this man does not stop talking
there's a girl on the show too so it's
like a nice dynamic but then the other
one he watches is
pti you ever listened to that one no
these two what does that stand for
pardon the interruption
i think it's part of my team no that's
the barstool podcast it's pti it's part
of the interruption there's two sp that
are pardoning themselves sports podcasts
that are part pardon isn't even like a
sports term not at all it's not like
it's goal you know yeah no but it's pti
and the two of them they really kiki and
like zach's been watching it since he
was like in middle school and like he
loves them yeah i guess that's how
people feel about the topes oh my god
totally
so yeah ben loves nba on tnt and like
they're just always like goofing around
like they make so much money to
literally sit there and like do nothing
i mean i guess
it's a job but like they're just like
kiking like literally just giggling and
and it's actually so good and i don't
really even like to watch basketball but
i don't mind like the shack moments
because you know shaq has
has that quality he's got the ben factor
he's got this like star quality
and i feel like it really translates
behind the scenes he's obviously a
really nice generous guy and i just
wanted to find a nice girl to settle
down with and it's khloe kardashian yeah
and they need to go on a date so if
you're one of those like publicist
cupids make it happen yeah publicist
qcids yeah also the only thing about the
sports shows is like they have the same
conversation over and over again yeah
and
it's giving like a pre-show because they
predict what's gonna happen in a game
and it's like can we just watch the game
and then talk about what happened no if
i was ever president which you would all
be so lucky to have um there would be a
rule like outlawing pre-shows for major
events like
people just sitting around guessing what
they think is going to happen at an
award show what people are going to wear
or how many points other team is going
to score is mind-numbingly stupid and is
a waste of everyone's time and energy
and resources and i think collectively
as a society it makes us dumber yeah so
that would be first day in office
banning that
second day in office all public water
fountains serve diet coke
and third day in office your vice
president me
bans the tortilla challenge oh
one of the dumbest things i've ever
participated in my life and if people
took the time they spent on that to i
don't know think about other things even
if it was just to sit in silence and
look inward there's a challenge going
around on tick-tock called the tortilla
challenge i made jackie do it yesterday
and while she is [ __ ] talking it now we
had such a good time and people are
loving the content so
it's literally
not that dude no but the fact that
people are going around making videos
like that
watching videos like you just never
understand us you'll never understand
and i never want to okay and if
i almost came on tick tock you sent me
something yesterday and i said this is
going to be the thing that gets me a
tick tick tock i don't remember what it
was i think it was one of the scala
girls like sharing um oh yeah like home
design yeah yeah yeah yeah that could
have gotten me there but then
unfortunately the tortilla challenge set
me back set you back okay
um
love what are you talking about jack
shack
and pre-shows yeah so yeah
it's like even if you're right even if
you say the amount of points they're
going to score or what dress you know
someone's going to wear on their carpet
we don't care why do you win right what
did you get right i guess if but if you
could predict things like that
especially with points scored you could
make bets
yeah i just think it's so dumb beyond
period period i am ready to move on yeah
to our next story because gina
kirschenheiter has been accused of
pushing her boyfriend travis mullen
downstairs by
ex-wife
also in this picture gina is wearing the
dress that margot wore her birthday
party so that was just really
distracting me yeah to get that out here
are the details
gina kirschenheiter allegedly pushed her
boyfriend travis mullen down the stairs
during a fight that broke out at their
orange county home travis's ex-wife
megan mullen made the accusation in
court documents obtained by page six she
claims the physical altercation occurred
around april in front of the for the
former couple's ten-year-old daughter
presley so travis's daughter right and
obviously travis's ex-wife was there
like probably picking up or dropping off
the daughter yeah late at night the
children started hearing loud noises
presley went out of the room to
investigate travis was yelling that gina
was an alcoholic
megan alleges in the court docks presley
witnessed gina pushed travis down the
stairs banging his head on the wall and
throwing hairs and pictures off the wall
megan alleges in the docs that she
instructed her kids to call the police
if this ever happens again those cell
phones are allegedly not allowed at
travis and gina's home all three
children have expressed to me says megan
that they are not allowed to call me
during his visits
in addition to the alleged physical
incident megan also states that she she
is concerned about gina's behavior in
drinking the kids tell me that sometimes
when they wake up in the morning she'll
be asleep with an empty bottle of wine
and a glass next to her
a source close to gina tells page six
that these allegations are completely
false quote these claims are without
merit this is a false narrative that
megan is trying to paint about gina who
is a domestic abuse survivor
okay so there's so many interesting like
things that have happened to gina that
now like feel really relevant like she
had a dui
and the way she described it was that
she was at a lularoe party
right and she like had one and like
forgot and so she drove and like i guess
when she said that like i actually did
believe her but hearing this it like it
just does feel like a relative back to
that yeah yes um and what's so crazy is
that gina has
in her previous marriage been a victim
of domestic violence
so this is like really crazy this is
really crazy and the reason why
these docs were filed were in response
to travis's request for an emergency
investigation into claims that uh the
ex-wife was unlawfully keeping the kids
from him she alleges it's actually the
kids who are refusing to visit with him
so i mean i mean if you if your kids
were spending time with your husband and
a woman who you believe to be an
alcoholic dangerous musically abusing
your ex-husband so is allegedly abusive
i don't know anymore right are the kids
witnessing it but you're gonna have them
in the same i
goodbye yeah no i don't know any mom
that would like willingly happily fork
her kids over
to a situation that sounds so toxic yeah
that is so crazy
and i i feel like gina had like a really
rough like one or two years with the dui
the divorce and the domestic violence
case and like the last two years have
been like renaissance gina new man
casita the whole thing and this is just
like bringing her back
like maybe gina is like extremely toxic
yeah because that's what it sounds like
this is like kind of crazy this is
really crazy
and like i guess i could also see a
world in which like this ex-wife like is
jealous of gina and like made up these
lies i could see she wants full custody
of her kids so she's gonna you know say
anything about this woman who does have
a his a dui
is a public figure so this all comes to
the forefront and and becomes a bigger
deal right so yes that's true i could
see that being possible too but
i don't know what woman would quote her
kids in this way but i don't know this
woman at all that's a thing like yeah
she could be nuts yeah but i don't know
it sounds like a lot of what she's
saying like harks back to things that we
know about gina yeah this is a crazy
story
i hope gina's okay because it doesn't
sound like it no and i hope the travis
is okay oh right downstairs yeah that's
the kids are okay the kids
we shall see we shall see our fifth and
final story a little nostalgic news are
you ready for it
microsoft's internet explorer browser is
officially done so i heard about this
internet explorer the once popular web
browser from tech giant microsoft has
died the software program was 26 younger
than your girl internet explorer also
known as ie nobody called it that
not a soul question question mark
variety
is survived by microsoft edge the
browser the company launched in 2015
that very few people use thank you for
the honesty um the company had
previously announced that it would see
support for internet explorer on june 15
2022 today touting the supposed
superiority of edge not only is
microsoft edge a faster more secure and
more modern browsing experience than
internet explorer but is also able to
address a key concern compatibility for
older legacy websites and apps why not
just
re-brand like why did there have to be
two why couldn't internet explorer get a
reboot get the tech that edge has they
can even change the name like i like the
name we're exploring the internet why
not it's really it's extremely nostalgic
like that big e blue e logo with like
the yellow ring around it like that's
iconic um and this is just like this is
part of growing up you know
losing loved ones yep even though i
haven't used internet explorer probably
in 25 years no but it did just unlock a
memory i know like paint
what was that game with the
with the with the gray squares and you'd
like click and not get the bomb
click i don't know
it's not minecraft i like towers mine
sweeper minesweeper icy tower
ic tower was a mac thing icy tower was
so fun oh my god miniclip.com aqua
energizer
acknows energizer yeah yeah yeah and
then aqua the water version
good times oh my god good times
uh oh oh what was that
wacky packs do you remember wacky packs
like those cards yeah there wasn't an
internet thing yes there was there was a
website me and margo were obsessed with
it you would do like wacky pack like
games and like it was so fun damn yeah
it used to be lit those were the days
kids will never know if you're too busy
slapping each other with tortillas
you'll never know the joy of reaching a
new level in aknows energizer no you'll
never know of reaching a new high score
in icy tower
oh that little guy he was flipping he
was bouncing off the walls yeah but icy
tower is not the same
era as the because i played icy tower
like in high school on my mac you would
download it i remember nude
yeah i know why i see tower i think what
lasted like a long
yeah a long walk evolved
remember x moto
no nobody remembers x moto the it was
like a
a mac game the man on the on the bicycle
x moto you play a lot more games than i
do like something has to be like you
know i'm like a front a fun free spirit
brick breaker in order for me to play it
yeah yeah yeah you know yeah do you
remember snood yes
and i remember och no synergizer acknows
energizer when you think of snood what
do you think of on the counter i don't
think of anything you don't think of
olivia ashrae
she was snoot queen no oh my god then of
course there's limewire
oh of course snapster napster that was
like a little bit before my time oh
those were the days like i would hand
over my ipod to like you were olivia and
be like hook it up yeah and whatever
trash you guys are listening to like i
was obsessed with we've always been
music curating queens i'm not gonna lie
it's true you know making up dances
making up playlists gotta make up a
dance
that's what tick-tock is i guess but
like nothing will compare like making up
a dance of moves like you saw in movies
and stuff and then like doing it for
your parents in the living room yeah and
being a star yeah and like getting a
camcorder out yeah those are the days
like everyone wants to film you
literally like these days the kids get
filmed well first of all they learn
advances on tick tock and two their
parents film them 24 7 with their
iphones no it's like too much it's not
like a big deal i think it's actually a
bigger deal when your parents don't film
you and then you're like am i not cute
enough am i not important did i not
shine today totally where's that phone
where's that phone the fifth and final
that was the fifth and final goodbye
internet explorer thank you for the
memories you will be missed
end of an era
okay um the show's not over i don't want
you to cry or start sweating it's gonna
be okay because it's your toaster's time
which is our advice segment if you ever
want advice from your girlies every
wednesday we do a segment called dear
toasters you can write in your
submission whatever problem you're
having whether it's work-related hygiene
related friend related deertoasters
gmail.com we'll keep your name anonymous
of course and we'll do our best to dole
out some pretty good advice yeah we do
our best and we've changed some lives so
so watch your mouth so yeah and dear
toasters is brought to you by favor
previously the pill club favor is a
digital health company that sees the
whole you from birth control and sexual
wellness to skin care and menstrual care
all backed by medical experts so the
pill club is now favor and favor offers
professionally prescribed birth control
subscriptions and sexual wellness
products delivered straight to your door
favor carries over 120 fda approved
brands that ship to all 50 states most
brands of birth control are free with
insurance or medicaid and otherwise
their prices start as low as seven
dollars per month without insurance
favor delivers birth control to your
door for free and discreet packaging
along with fun self-care gifts and
goodies their licensed medical team is
just a text away to provide you with the
care that you deserve so you can sign up
for birth control in just five minutes
and skip the office and the waiting in
line at the pharmacy and get treated
right right now when you go to hey
favor.com
toast favor is offering a 10 donation to
bedcider.org for every morning toast
listener who becomes a patient your
donation will help low income
individuals get access to birth control
through bedsider.org that's hey
favor.com toast to get your first birth
control care package and donate to help
more women in need of affordable birth
control remember it's heyfavor.com toast
and you must use that link to get the
donation thank you so we have two
submissions and one update from a girly
um who wrote in a few weeks ago
so our first submission hello
jax
claude bryce and stress the stress
brothers miss them i am an og brother
here looking for some advice okay i
dated my ex maverick in 2018 for a
little over a year we've both moved on
but i recently moved back to my home
state and we are now pretty good friends
again since we run in the same friend
groups i was hanging out with him and my
friend ruth on saturday at his apartment
celebrating my birthday it was getting
late so i said i was ready to leave and
she got up and said she was gonna leave
also he walked us both to our cars and i
drove off well i have ruth's location
and she actually slept over instead of
leaving i didn't think anything of it at
the time since she was drinking and he
told us both we were more than welcome
to stay if we needed to
the next day i was hanging out with my
friend jill when ruth called her ruth
said she [ __ ] maverick and feels icky
since they are just friends but she made
jill swear not to tell me even though i
heard the whole conversation
it does bother me that they hooked up
since i literally oh sorry it does not
bother me that they hooked up since i
literally have no feelings for this man
anymore but it does bother me that she
is keeping the secret for me i know it's
just a hookup
but we have been friends for so long and
i do consider one of my best friends
should i call her out and let her know
it seems shady should i drop it entirely
am i overreacting since i truly don't
have feelings for this man anymore okay
this is like infuriating to read because
girl you are being walked over like a
[ __ ] doormat even if you don't
have feelings for this man the fact that
someone you said i consider her my best
friend slept with a guy you dated for a
year like that's low-key crazy and the
lying on top of it means she knows it's
crazy and that's why she's keeping it
from you and this girl sounds like a
bitc [ __ ] h like not your
friend sleeping with your ex bad not
telling you bad yeah telling someone
else being like don't tell
the toaster like you're kidding right
when you put it like that i do agree
when she wrapped up her
her statements i was like well if you
don't care who cares but yeah i guess
that's not a best friend the best
bretton does not sleep with your ex no
matter whether or not you still have
feelings for him like she could sleep
with him if they were otp and they were
going to get married and meet together
but they have to get married now but
just to like have sex with him your ex
like what or maybe that's what people do
in this friend group you know like i
mean sleep with each other you sound so
like
passe about it i'm like shook because
this is like an enormous betrayal even
if she had told you straight to your
face it's still a betrayal you did it
for a year
four years ago
still
but if they're all still friends
we don't we can't relate to this if
they're all still friends like it means
that he's no longer like he's not an ex
he's just like a friend in the group you
know he's not like that x that like we
don't see we don't know but if she went
out and slept with him that'd be [ __ ]
weird but like right so it sounds like
this group is extremely understanding so
the fact that jill
what's her name no yeah jill no jill
went to ruth
and if if the group is how you describe
it then she should have had no problem
just being upfront and telling her that
she stopped with her ex-boyfriend yeah
it's reminding me of vanderpump rules
you know yeah because it's like do you
still consider stassi and jack's exes
like if now you know what no like and if
someone take britney out of the equation
like if
later down the line like katie yeah but
katie should tell stassi yeah and not
just tell christina and if she had
nobody and if and if castasia had no
feelings like really didn't care then it
wouldn't be an issue right and you don't
have feelings for him so you don't care
but it's still lying makes it seem like
you're doing something wrong which i
guess you are yeah so what i would say
is just keep an eye on that one yeah
she's really she's not like an og friend
but you know who is ruth letting you
listen to the whole conversation yeah
there are nefarious things happening
yeah jill is not your girl no i think
ruth
is the nefarious one
sorry yeah ruth is the one who [ __ ]
but jill is jill is an og she's a she
goes hard for you because she let you
listen to the conversation yeah
what are these names jill and ruth
all right next up
dear claudia jackie harry bruno and theo
theo getting
shitty billing
long time toaster here first time ever
writing in over the weekend my p john
boyfriend and i moved to my hometown in
florida after graduating from dental
school
we've been dating for two and a half
years but we both come from super
conservative christian and catholic
families for reference i'm 27 and he's
29 and we don't live we don't want to
live together until marriage while
moving my sweet innocent naive
mother-in-law a mother mother who was
helping me found his condoms and
discovered them right in front of me
mind you they were magnum xl
she looked at me absolutely mortified
and then left his apartment immediately
i've seen her since and it's incredibly
awkward and i have a huge pit about it
i'm afraid she's going to confront me
and i don't know what to say as she
definitely had no idea i was having sex
or have you even had sex what do i do do
i pretend she didn't see anything do i
confront the issue do i lie if she asks
do i tell her that her little girl is
grown up and is having amazing sex
please advise as my best friend who's
also a toaster said this one's for
jackson claude sincerely an incredibly
embarrassed okay this was her mom not
her mother her mom and she's 27 but her
parents are like uber uber religion i
guess they were under the assumption
that she would not be having sex till
marriage because she's not moving in
okay with him until she's married okay
first of all i would say follow her lead
if she wants to pretend like she didn't
see it you take it you count your
blessings great and you don't have to
have a conversation about it if she does
bring it up don't lie because then that
means that he's cheating on you with
someone else right then he looks bad
just be honest be like listen this is
the person i am going to be with i know
it's not what you would do but i do i
feel very comfortable i'm old enough to
make that decision we're being safe
magnum xl yes
and
i hope that you can understand that i
wouldn't start saying you're having
amazing sex no need to like i just don't
think that's any of your mother's
business yeah but just be like you know
we've wait we like i don't know what the
truth is but you could say like we
waited a while in our relationship till
we knew we were like certain about each
other and though i do like have so much
respect for all the traditional values
we were raised with and so many of them
i do want i do incorporate into my own
life like i am you know a modern woman
this is good and
that was something that that decision
that we came to and
things are good i hope you can respect
it that's good [ __ ] but agreed on the
first part if homegirl doesn't say
anything you shut the [ __ ] up like yeah
follow her lead like it's awkward it's
not like she's angry at you because if
she was she would yell at you she's your
[ __ ] mom yeah but and maybe she's not
upset about it at all but in that moment
it's a lot to process okay
my daughter's grown up yes and she
probably thought up until this point
like that that was not happening she's
going to become a dentist like [ __ ] you
can have right of course but let her
react in her own time yeah
and if if she doesn't want to talk about
it with you because she has she knows
what she needs to know really what's
what's the question magnum what's the
question magnum
magnum but so
from your head like you're not having
sex but like you guys don't need to talk
about it like she knows great yeah move
on but if she wants to talk about it
just i would come from it come to it
from a respectful pov considering like
you do share a lot of the same values
and you know what
she really can't be mad that you're
being extremely safe like
she raised a smart capable and cautious
daughter and we love that it's honestly
a compliment to her yeah to find those
condoms look what i did
i raised a smart
health-conscious woman who's gonna be a
doctor who pulled a magnum
right and her boyfriend's got a big dick
i've never been so proud of my daughter
and mine because she had to leave
because she was overwhelmed with emotion
and pride totally
you did that congratulations congrats
all right our third and final deer
toasters is an update so this happened
when taylor strecker was here i have the
girl submission but i can give you the
the gist of the gist um she made a new
friend with a girl who was this toaster
made a friend and this girl is great and
she really liked her but she literally
cannot go out to eat with her like she
literally eats so aggressively shoveling
like a cobb salad in her mouth with her
hands
no like eating dressing all over her
face she didn't put her napkin on her
lap she was chewing with her mouth open
talking while eating lettuce flying out
of her mouth she said it was very
upsetting and
she was gonna overlook it until she
started picking up the salad with her
hands
okay so she didn't know what to do what
was the advice
we said um go out for smoothies no okay
here look so hi i wrote into deer
toasters in late april asking for advice
on my friend who's a messy eater she
picked up the cobb salad with her hands
claudia and taylor provided some
wonderful advice and confirmed that it
was indeed gross i think we said like
stop going out to eat with her like why
do you guys go bowling or something um
and also like maybe go out in a group so
that like other people can see it like
maybe someone else will say something or
just order finger food right right
that's good advice
so here's what she did as disgusted as i
am i've determined that it's not worth
ending our friendship over since i
really do genuinely like this girl but
i've made it a point to prioritize
activities other than eating we went to
a concert recently for example i've
gotten dinner with her twice since then
and both have been with a big group so i
just sat next to her instead of a cross
from her so i don't have to watch her
eating someone in toast after dark
actually suggested this and i'm so glad
that they did our friendship is stronger
than ever because of it thanks queens
look at this this is what we mean you
guys that's excellent advice to sit next
to someone like in a booth as opposed to
directly across from them because
there's no escaping it if you're
directly across gorgeous i love that
advice i'm so glad that worked out and
you know what like normalize looking
past people's flaws because people
are complex
and people are flawed but on the inside
it's it's the good inside that that's
what matters of course
and that's proverbs john 22 luke 8 5.
thank you lucas 12 16. you're welcome
sarah 85. i like maverick 2030. it's my
favorite passage
it's so uplifting
he who shall once love claudia shall
never love again so [ __ ] true
um
okay those were your toasters again if
you want to submit it's dear toasters at
gmail.com that was our show but if
you're looking for more content join us
tonight spotify live our new show
breaking bread premieres at 7 p.m
eastern time 4 p.m pacific time it is a
totally live audio show on the spotify
live app you can also tune in live on
spotify um make sure to follow our show
breaking bread on spotify thank you so
much for listening to the morning toast
the millennial morning show where we
deliver the fast five stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
on youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give us video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcasts
can be found so that's spotify itunes
stitcher public radio i have radio cast
box all the places so wherever you
listen to podcast find us the morning
chosen leave a five-star review about
how beautiful stunning and smart we are
have an amazing day you guys we'll see
you tomorrow we will see you tomorrow
goodbye
don't wait don't end did we end
tomorrow's episode is podcast only
um so it'll be up early tomorrow morning
jackie and i are both oh my gosh you
scared me i thought you saw like a mouse
or something i didn't realize you were
mocking me i should be used to it by now
oh my god my heart actually just stopped
are you for real because you pointed i
thought it was literally a mouse by my
foot like we live in new york [ __ ] like
a roach no nothing just a dirty carpet
and yes we know the carpet needs to be
cleaned you know what we're not doing it
um thursday tomorrow's episode is
podcast only and there's no show friday
and monday of this week and next week so
i just want to say that thank you for
stopping my heart i have to go to the
hospital now have a great day anything
else you want to say um no just goodbye
everyone have a wonderful weekend make
sure to meditate i'll see you tomorrow
for podcasters meditating technology
space that you're in and bryson's and
you'll see them tonight and they'll see
you tonight on breaking bread bryce
detroit bye
we should have called the show bryce and
streisand totally
you